meine haben ist flughafen meine damen
und herren jeder weiß dass ich ein apfel
bin
von daher unterhalte ich mich heute mit
einem bruder von mir so wie geht's dir
du und du
müsste das nicht und die heißt deutsche
grammatik kannst du wohl nicht so gut
wie maschinenpistole mit
grammatikalische fehler in meiner seien
von der eigentlichen tatsache dass bp
nach hinten
ja ich bin eine maschine
ich bin ganz ehrlich tigger ich weiß
nicht was du mir hier mitteilen willst
warum angucken immer warum gedachten
farben ein mega ich meine ich weiß nicht
was du mir mitteilen willst das hat
nichts mit der farbe weiß zu tun
google.com recht machen ich bin das
beste beispiel für weiß ja okay ich
meine ich bin weiß aber reden wir mal
über was anderes m wie geht es dir denn
eigentlich angefangen mit köpfchen so an
mir verteidigen
ich wollte eigentlich nur wissen wie es
ihr geht und nicht dass irgendwelche
frauen mit körbchengröße d an dir vorbei
joggen aber gut okay wenn du mir das
erzählen möchte ist selbstverständlich
was machst du denn heute noch so über
die person mit der ich hier gerade rede
also der affe ist ein neuer bot von der
website clever bot was hab ich aber mit
dem clever wort gesprochen im sinne von
ich schreib benachrichtigen in dem chat
und der clever bord antwortete gegend
einer wirren nachricht aber das hier ist
verwirrung auf einem komplett neuen
niveau ich frage den affen jetzt etwas
komplett simpel ist und zwar einfach nur
was ist dein name
ja das macht definitiv sind die mein
heutiges ziel es ist jetzt wirklich
einfach nur noch herauszufinden was der
name von diesen affen zu hoch lukas und
nicht an junge und seehäfen 24 monaten
zusammen
ok ich heiße zwar nicht klug hast
sondern luca aber schon ziemlich nah
dran und angeblich sind wir seit vier
monaten zusammen also keine ahnung hab
ich davon nichts wusste aber warum sind
wir ein paar wochen buchungsstellen
berühren berühre ich an meinem schnell
was für stellen meinst du genau wofür
vermutlich zum beispiel oder und da
schon rennen oder in der schule
kannst du dich bitte mal erklären bruder
was willst du denn jetzt hier mitteilen
ich dachte wir sind seit vier monaten
ein paar
ich meine wir haben wir uns denn
kennengelernt war langen brücke auf die
ja du kannst mich umarmen dann auf
klares wort ich finde dich da
das ist ja mega lieben und vorgestellt
und für hat uns gefragt ob sie lernen
kann
also ich mein hobby schule auch
kennengelernt ist einfach gesehen ob sie
gefangen hält zusammen sein und fakten
dennoch will ich immer noch wissen die
der affe überhaupt heißt weil wir sind
angeblich seit vier monaten zusammen
schweißen nicht seinen namen
also ich bin mit einem affen namens lisa
zusammen seit vier monaten aber sein
roboter name ist codiert und pop punk
rocker und nach minuten komisch aber ich
liege ja angeblich auch nicht mal
persönlich dieser ich will jetzt endlich
wissen was sache zwischen uns beiden
jetzt sind wir jetzt ein pärchen oder
kennen wir uns nicht ob wir an einnahmen
daraus so sehe ich das eigentlich auch
lisa bzw kathi ich will jetzt hier
wirklich zum ende des videos nicht zu
nahe treten aber ich glaube das wird
nichts mehr zwischen und sind jetzt
schon vier monate zusammen aber ich
möchte jetzt einfach sagen ich mach
schluss nur vage monika lang gezogenen
gepäck und auch nicht genug freunde also
ganz viele von euch haben unter meinen
letzten clever bordvideos geschrieben er
luca du musst unbedingt man mit dem
schwimmbad reden das ist von clever bot
eine gemachte simulation eines affen und
du kannst mir diesen affen reden und er
antwortet wirklich immer mega super ich
das video hier auf jeden fall gefallen
da würde ich mich sehr darüber einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freuen schreibt mir zu denen auch
gerne in die kommentare ob ich in einer
woche noch mal mit dem schwimmbad reden
soll und über welches thema also könnt
mir einmal fragen und in die kommentare
schreiben abonniert zudem gern meinen
kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der luke rusal
dadurch verpasste keine videos mehr und
krieg direkt mit wenn ich nächste woche
wieder mit dem schimpfwort rede und wenn
ihr schon einmal eine zeit wo ich mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr auf die glocke
klickt dann bekommt ihr zudem noch eine
benachrichtigung sobald ein neues video
online gehen und werde 60 prozent der
leute die sich meine videos anschauen
gar nicht abonnent sind also leute ist
es kostenlos klick darauf und jetzt
kommt das auto
[Musik]
katzen können nicht am computer sitzen
und schreiben und lesen
[Musik]